Nous sommes en 1911.
Freud, le fondateur de la psychanalyse, et
Jung, son plus célèbre disciple, déjeunent
ensemble à Munich.
Freud lui reproche d’avoir publié des articles
dans des journaux suisses sans mentionner
son nom.
Jung rétorque que c’est inutile, parce
que son nom est déjà très connu.
Mais Freud insiste.
Qu’on l’oublie dans l’article lui déplaît
vraiment ; ça le blesse.
Et puis soudain…
il s’évanouit.
Ce n’est pas la première fois qu’il fait
ça devant Jung.
Comment Freud l’explique-t-il ?
« C’est parce que je sens qu’inconsciemment,
tu veux me tuer », dit-il à Jung.
Certains disent que Freud est le « Newton
de l’esprit ».
Leur idée, c’est que Freud a révolutionné
notre manière de comprendre le monde psychique
comme Newton avait révolutionné notre manière
de comprendre le monde physique.
C’est peut-être excessif dans la mesure
où Newton est un véritable scientifique
— mais il est certain que Freud a eu une
ÉNORME influence dans la culture occidentale.
Ses idées ont pénétré la sagesse populaire
dont l’homme ordinaire se sert dans sa vie
quotidienne.
On peut carrément dire qu’elles ont révolutionné
les mentalités.
Elles sont notamment une des forces à l’origine
de la révolution des mœurs des années 1960.
La sociologue américaine Sherry Turkle dit
dans La France freudienne que la psychanalyse
s’est massifiée parce qu’elle légitime
les conversations sur le sexe et parce qu’elle
justifie rationnellement la libération sexuelle.
Bref, les idées de Freud ont changé le monde.
Mais comme la réputation de la psychanalyse
dépend en bonne partie de la réputation
de son fondateur, c’est souvent la légende
de Freud qu’on nous sert
— on oublie, consciemment ou inconsciemment,
les aspects peu reluisants de son parcours,
ceux qui nous amèneraient à douter de la
psychanalyse.
Moi, je vais vous raconter 10 anecdotes sur
la vie de Freud — des anecdotes étonnantes,
et surtout révélatrices concernant la psychanalyse
et son fondateur.
Je pense que vous allez être scandalisés
par les dernières anecdotes.
Dites-moi si c’est le cas dans les commentaires.
Vous avez déjà entendu parler du complexe
d’Œdipe ?
C’est l’idée que le petit garçon désire
inconsciemment sa mère, et que pour réaliser
ce désir il a envie de tuer son père.
Dans le mythe grec qui donne son nom au complexe,
Œdipe tue carrément son père et épouse
sa mère.
Cette situation qui se réalise dans la légende
serait présente à l’état de désir dans
toute âme de petit garçon.
Mais d’où Freud tire-t-il cette prétendue
vérité psychologique universelle ?
Eh bien de son propre cas, semble-t-il.
Il est né d’un père de 41 ans et d’une
mère de 21 ans, différence d’âge qui
est liée au fait que c’était le troisième
mariage du père.
Et la différence explique en partie l’attitude
de l’enfant Freud.
Il est très proche de sa mère, qui est une
belle jeune femme
— tandis qu’il fuit son vieux père dont
la présence ne lui est pas agréable.
Au début de la quarantaine, il se souvient
même d’une scène précise.
Lorsqu’il avait trois quatre ans, il a vu
sa mère nue au cours d’un voyage de nuit
en train.
Le fondateur de la psychanalyse estime que
c’est la naissance de son désir pour sa
mère.
Ce que montre cette anecdote, c’est qu’il
est fort possible que Freud ait tout simplement
généralisé son cas personnel.
D’ailleurs, ce soupçon n’est pas nouveau.
C’est une attaque récurrente contre la
psychanalyse au tout début du XXe siècle
:
ses lois (entre guillemets) généraliseraient
les traumatismes personnels de son fondateur.
Freud prétend lire les pensées des autres,
mais il ne ferait que lire ses propres pensées.
Si l’enfant Sigmund Freud aime sa mère,
elle le lui rend bien.
L’amour de cette femme belle et énergique
lui donne précocement la motivation et la
confiance en soi pour aller chercher la gloire.
Mais c’est plus généralement sa famille
entière qui croit en Freud.
Il est l’enfant préféré, promis à un
destin exceptionnel.
Lorsque son intérêt entre en conflit avec
celui de ses sœurs, les parents tranchent
systématiquement en sa faveur.
Par exemple, il se plaint que les leçons
de piano de sa sœur Anna l’empêchent de
se concentrer sur ses livres d’école.
Résultat ? Le piano disparaît.
Et pourtant, un piano, à l’époque, c’est
un attribut indispensable pour une famille
de la classe moyenne en Europe centrale.
Mais la future gloire de Sigmund justifie
le sacrifice.
En fait, les parents ne font même pas semblant
de traiter les enfants de manière égale.
Ils accordent à Sigmund, et à lui seul,
un bureau privé, une pièce longue et étroite
avec une fenêtre donnant sur la rue.
Bref, ils croient à fond en son potentiel
— donc ils veulent le mettre dans les meilleures
conditions afin qu’il réalise ce potentiel.
Ce que montre cette anecdote, c’est qu’on
trouve dans le destin de Freud l’ingrédient
que l’on trouve dans les destins de l’immense
majorité des individus qui accomplissent
de grandes choses :
une stimulation, ou un conditionnement si
on veut, initiale.
Et pour le coup, la psychanalyse dit des choses
convaincantes à ce propos.
Effectivement, il semble que les aptitudes
de l’adulte soient souvent forgées dans
l’enfance, et donc dans le milieu familial.
L’enfance peut être un poids, ou bien,
comme celle de Freud, un tremplin.
Je me souviens avoir lu dans un roman français
— je n’ai pas retrouvé la citation —
que croire en soi ne suffit pas pour réussir
de grandes choses ;
qu’il faut encore que d’autres personnes
croient en nous, et que leur foi alimente
notre motivation.
Je trouve que l’enfance de Freud illustre
bien cette idée.
Enfant, Freud a souvent entendu une légende
à propos de sa naissance.
Alors que sa mère était heureuse d’avoir
accouché de son premier-né, une vieille
paysanne lui aurait prophétisé qu’elle
venait de donner au monde un grand homme.
Les parents de Freud sont persuadés qu’il
a un grand destin.
Et il a beau galérer à l’âge adulte,
ils y croient encore.
Par exemple, pour ses 35 ans, son père lui
offre une Bible dans laquelle il a écrit,
en hébreu, que l’esprit de Dieu l’a guidé
vers le savoir depuis l’âge de 7 ans.
Non seulement il est l’enfant préféré,
mais sa famille nourrit en lui une énorme
ambition.
Ses parents lui répètent qu’il est exceptionnellement
intelligent.
Et ses résultats scolaires confirment leurs
attentes extravagantes :
il est un élève brillant — toujours premier
de sa classe — et un modèle pour les autres.
Il passe tout son temps dans le bureau privé
que lui réservent ses parents.
Il travaille tout le temps, même quand des
amis viennent le voir ; il prend ses repas
seul pour ne pas arrêter de travailler.
Bref, Freud est un incroyable bûcheur.
Et son excellence scolaire le confirme dans
la conviction qu’il est promis à un grand
avenir.
Son ambition ne le quittera jamais — même
quand il cherchera sa voie, même quand il
n’arrivera pas à percer.
Sa puissance de travail ne le quittera pas
non plus.
Une fois qu’il aura son cabinet, il organisera
sa vie — et celle de sa famille — de manière
très routinière
afin de pouvoir multiplier les consultations
tout en gardant assez de temps pour lire et
écrire
(généralement en soirée, après le dîner).
Extérieurement, Freud est un conservateur
— mais les apparences sont trompeuses.
Il a beau vivre comme un bourgeois, son ambition
ne s’accommode pas de la morale bourgeoise.
Il a beau vouloir passer pour un scientifique,
son ambition ne s’accommode ni de la prudence
ni de la rigueur austères de la science.
Voici comment il se décrit à un ami en 1900
: « Je ne suis pas du tout un homme de science,
pas un observateur, pas un expérimentateur,
pas un penseur.
Je ne suis rien d'autre qu'un conquistador
par tempérament, un aventurier si l'on veut
traduire ce terme, avec toute la curiosité,
l'audace et la ténacité d'un tel homme ».
Ce que montre cette anecdote, c’est que
Freud n’a pas eu une grande influence GRÂCE
à sa découverte des lois de l’esprit humain
;
Freud voulait devenir un grand homme DÈS
LE DÉPART.
La question que je me pose, c’est : est-ce
que son ambition démesurée ne l’a pas
entraîné à privilégier systématiquement
l’originalité à la vérité ?
Le bureau privé où le petit Sigmund Freud
passe tout son temps est bourré de livres.
L’enfant passe la plupart de son temps dans
les livres.
À l’adolescence, ça continue : il lit
énormément.
Principalement de la littérature classique
et de la philosophie.
Comme ses parents croient en son destin, ils
mettent volontiers la main au portefeuille.
Mais une fois que Freud est un jeune adulte
indépendant, ça devient compliqué pour
lui de financer sa boulimie de lectures.
Eh oui, à l’époque, c’est pas 99 centimes
sur Amazon.
Dans sa vingtaine, Freud a beau être un médecin
débutant avec de maigres ressources, qui
fait attention au moindre euro, il continue
d’acheter beaucoup de livres !
Il ne peut pas s’en empêcher !
Je suis un peu comme lui…
Seulement, à plusieurs reprises, ses dépenses
de livres le mettent sur le fil du rasoir,
financièrement parlant.
Par exemple, en 1900, à la mort de Nietzsche,
il dépense beaucoup d’argent pour acheter
l’intégral du philosophe allemand.
Et tous ces achats ne servent pas à faire
beau dans la bibliothèque.
Freud continue de lire comme un affamé.
Il passe des heures dans les bouquins chaque
jour, souvent jusque tard dans la nuit.
Je ne sais pas s’il a lu le conseil de Schopenhauer
dans Parerga et Paralipomena, mais Freud lit
uniquement des classiques.
Les grandes œuvres de la Grèce antique,
Rabelais, Shakespeare, Molière, Goethe, etc.
Résultat des courses ?
Eh bien Freud est HYPER cultivé.
Dans sa vingtaine, il lit énormément de
philosophie.
D’ailleurs, en 3ème année de fac de médecine,
il hésite à se lancer dans un doctorat de
philosophie — mais finalement il renonce.
Ça ne l’empêche pas d’être un érudit,
passionné par les idées.
Et ce qui est encore plus important… c’est
qu’il va cacher son érudition !
Eh oui, comme la psychologie s’est émancipée
de la philosophie au XIXe siècle, Freud a
peur que son érudition philosophique nuise
à la réputation de ses théories psychologiques,
que les professionnels refusent de les considérer
comme des théories scientifiques s’ils
perçoivent l’influence de théories philosophiques.
Quand on lui demande d’où viennent ses
théories, il admet avoir lu les travaux de
psychologues, de médecins
— bref d’auteurs qui ont un crédit scientifique
—
et il admet sans problème que ces travaux
ont pu l’influencer.
Mais il n’évoque pas l’influence des
philosophes.
Par exemple, il raconte qu’il se saigne
pour acheter l’intégral de Nietzsche, MAIS
il ajoute qu’il n’ouvre même pas les
bouquins…
Ça, j’ai du mal à le croire.
Il nie toujours la probable origine philosophique
de ses concepts.
Par exemple, Schopenhauer et Nietzsche avaient
insisté sur le fait qu’il ne faut pas sous-estimer
les forces inconscientes de l’esprit.
Mais Freud n’évoque pas ces penseurs quand
il parle de l’inconscient
(qui est en réalité une idée très ancienne,
déjà présente chez Platon, par exemple).
Que révèle cette anecdote ?
Elle révèle que Freud n’est pas un simple
médecin, un pur scientifique.
Bien au contraire, il a beau avoir renoncé
à étudier la philo à l’université, il
a une culture littéraire et philosophique
digne d’un grand penseur.
Mais voilà, il ne veut surtout pas que la
psychanalyse passe pour une théorie philosophique…
Adolescent, à l’heure de choisir sa voie
professionnelle, Freud hésite.
Il est tenté d’imiter son meilleur ami
de l’époque, qui choisit le droit avec
l’intention de faire de la politique.
Mais Freud décide de s’inscrire en médecine.
Qu’est-ce qui le fait changer d’avis ?
Son admiration pour Darwin.
L'Origine des espèces, le chef-d’œuvre
de Darwin qui a changé la vision du monde
des Occidentaux, est sorti 3 ans après la
naissance de Freud.
Et depuis, le naturaliste anglais est devenu
une star scientifique.
Il est un idéal, un modèle pour beaucoup
de jeunes.
De l’adolescence au tout début de la fac
de médecine, si on demande à Freud quel
est son rêve, il répond : « un navire sur
l'océan avec tous les instruments dont le
chercheur a besoin »
(il fait référence au mythique voyage de
Darwin sur le Beagle, qui a accouché de la
théorie de l’évolution).
Cette anecdote montre que Freud n’est pas
un pur littéraire, un érudit qui aurait
fait médecine par dépit.
Son énorme ambition a donc 2 faces : littéraire
ET scientifique.
D’ailleurs, sa théorie de l’esprit sera
empirique, et il voudra même lui donner des
fondements physiologiques
(notamment, il travaillera beaucoup sur le
système nerveux, au début de sa carrière).
La psychanalyse sera finalement une doctrine
plutôt abstraite, à la scientificité douteuse,
mais Darwin restera un modèle pour Freud.
Il se comparera à lui en disant que le développement
de la science a infligé 3 blessures narcissiques
à l’humanité :
Copernic a établi que la Terre n’est pas
au centre de l’univers ;
Darwin que l’homme est un animal comme les
autres ;
et enfin Freud que l’homme n’est pas maître
de son propre esprit.
C’est vrai que les idées de Freud, comme
celles de Darwin, ont rapidement pénétré
la culture occidentale jusqu’à devenir
des piliers de la mentalité de l’homme
moderne.
Comme vous le savez, les études de médecine,
c’est pas l’histoire de 2-3 ans.
À presque 30 ans, Freud obtient une bourse
pour se rendre à Paris.
Il va se former auprès du neurologue Jean-Martin
Charcot, à l'École de la Salpêtrière.
Ça vous dit quelque chose Jean-Martin Charcot
?
C’est le grand nom de l’hypnose à la
fin du XIXe siècle.
Alors que l’hypnose n’était pas considérée
comme un sujet sérieux en France, Charcot
la fait sortir de la dissidence en la présentant
comme un outil de vivisection psychologique.
Il prétend notamment qu’elle permet de
comprendre l’hystérie
— l’hystérie, c’est un ensemble de
troubles corporels (par exemple, des crises
nerveuses, des convulsions) qui n’ont pas
leur origine dans le corps, mais dans l’esprit.
À l’époque, Charcot est une véritable
star.
Il est un personnage mondain de la haute société
; il soigne les grands du monde ; et il fait
des cours remarquables.
Son service à la Salpêtrière fascine les
jeunes savants philosophes.
Sa renommée dépasse les frontières : lorsqu’il
effectue un voyage en Russie, par exemple,
il est célébré comme un thaumaturge.
Bien sûr, Freud est sous le charme.
Voici ce qu’il écrit dans une lettre à
sa fiancée : « Charcot est un des plus grands
médecins, sa raison confine au génie.
»
Il faut dire que Charcot est très éloquent,
qu’il a beaucoup de charisme
— et ça joue forcément dans son succès
en tant qu’hypnotiseur.
Seulement, Freud, lui, n’aura pas autant
de succès avec l’hypnose.
Il s’en sert quand il revient à Vienne
(et ça ne plaît pas beaucoup à ses collègues).
Mais voilà, ses patients à lui ne se laissent
pas hypnotiser.
Moi qui me suis intéressé à l’hypnose,
j’ai compris que le succès de la méthode
dépend à la fois de la réceptivité de
l’hypnotisé et de la compétence de l’hypnotiseur.
Et apparemment, Freud, lui, est loin du niveau
de Charcot.
En fait, la psychanalyse naîtra, en tant
que pratique thérapeutique, de l’abandon
progressif de l’hypnose dans les années
1890.
Freud la remplace par la méthode de l’association
libre,
qui consiste à laisser le patient exprimer,
sans aucun contrôle, les pensées qui lui
viennent les unes après les autres.
Que tirer de cette anecdote ?
Je pense que la mode de l’hypnose de la
fin du XIXe siècle explique, au moins en
partie, pourquoi Freud insistera sur l’importance
de l’inconscient.
Quand une personne est sous hypnose, c’est
comme si elle était quelqu’un d’autre
;
et cette seconde partie d’elle-même a la
capacité de créer des blocages chez la première,
ou bien, au contraire, de libérer son potentiel.
Il y aurait donc en réalité deux personnes
chez l’être humain.
Et le psychanalyste, comme l’hypnothérapeute,
agit sur la partie inconsciente de l’être
humain, pour le bénéfice de la partie consciente.
À 26 ans, Freud rencontre Martha Bernays.
Cette femme de 21 ans est intelligente — elle
aime beaucoup les livres, comme lui — et
elle est séduisante (elle plaît aux hommes).
Deux mois seulement après leur première
rencontre, ils se fiancent.
Mais voilà, il y a une ombre au tableau.
C’est d’ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
la mère de Martha préférerait que sa fille
explore d’autres options.
C’est quoi le problème ?
Freud est pauvre.
Certes, Martha n’est pas riche — mais
elle est une fille de bonne famille.
Freud, lui, n’a ni le prestige social ni
l’aisance financière.
Après, la mère de Martha reconnaît que
Freud est brillant.
Mais elle ne l’imagine pas percer rapidement.
Elle pense qu’il va galérer pendant longtemps
avant de faire une grande découverte scientifique,
d’atteindre la notoriété et la prospérité.
Et…
elle a raison !
Martha et Sigmund vont devoir attendre 4 ans
avant de pouvoir se marier.
Ils attendent parce que Sigmund a posé une
condition :
il doit d’abord créer son cabinet de consultation,
dont il tirera une source de revenu fiable
pour subvenir aux besoins de sa famille.
Avant que cette condition soit réalisée,
c’est la galère.
Le jeune Freud se plaint de sa pauvreté dans
ses lettres à sa fiancée.
Il doit même emprunter de l’argent à des
collègues de travail.
Cette période de difficulté financière
est d’autant plus difficile à vivre pour
lui qu’il a peur que Martha le lâche à
un moment pour un meilleur parti.
À 30 ans, il a enfin son cabinet — donc
le mariage est possible.
Néanmoins, l’argent ne sort pas de sa tête
pour autant.
Il gagne plutôt bien sa vie — mais comme
il a une profession libérale, ses revenus
fluctuent.
Et lorsqu’il est dans le creux de la vague,
l’angoisse monte en lui.
Il a peur de retomber dans la pauvreté, de
revivre ce qu’il a vécu pendant les 4 années
au cours desquelles il a attendu de pouvoir
se marier.
Il partage encore cette angoisse dans des
lettres alors qu’il a la quarantaine !
Cette anecdote montre que Freud a un rapport
particulier à l’argent.
Mais ce qu’elle montre précisément, ce
n’est pas qu’il veut être riche, vivre
dans le luxe,
dépenser des sommes folles pour se faire
plaisir ou pour impressionner les gens.
Non, ce n’est pas ça.
Freud veut gagner de l’argent parce qu’il
a été traumatisé par la pauvreté.
En particulier, la pauvreté a failli lui
coûter la femme de sa vie.
Certains se scandalisent aujourd’hui qu’une
séance avec Freud pouvait coûter jusqu’à
grosso modo 500 euros de l’heure.
C’est vrai qu’une fois devenu célèbre,
il n’hésitera pas à imposer des tarifs
très élevés aux riches patients (américains
notamment) attirés par sa notoriété.
Mais il faut remettre les choses en perspective.
Voilà un homme qui a travaillé comme un
chien depuis l’enfance ;
qui, dans la quarantaine, alors qu’il est
père de famille, a encore peur de ne pas
pouvoir subvenir aux besoins de ses enfants
et de sa femme ;
et qui n’a pas emprunté des raccourcis
pour devenir riche ou célèbre.
Oui, Freud voulait gagner beaucoup d’argent
— et il en a gagné beaucoup grâce à la
psychanalyse dans la seconde moitié de sa
vie.
Mais il a énormément travaillé, et il n’a
volé personne.
Comme je vous l’ai dit, Charcot, le neurologue
qui a formé Freud à l’hypnose à Paris
— ce neurologue était un personnage mondain.
Il organisait des réceptions auxquelles Freud
était invité.
Et la première fois, Freud est particulièrement
stressé.
Il est très impressionné par la maison de
Charcot
— qui est plutôt un palais, en fait —
Freud n’est pas très à l’aise dans son
costume ;
et en plus, il a peur de se ridiculiser en
parlant français.
Que fait-il pour se donner du courage ?
Il se fait une ligne de cocaïne !
Il a découvert la poudre blanche 2 ans plus
tôt.
Lorsqu’il apprend qu’un médecin de l’armée
s’en sert pour stimuler l’endurance des
soldats, il décide de s’y intéresser.
Il pense que la cocaïne peut servir pour
réduire les troubles cardiaques, pour combattre
la dépression,
pour des anesthésies locales, et pour réduire
l’addiction à la morphine.
Le problème avec cette dernière idée, c’est
que le patient… devient accro à la cocaïne.
Donc ça ne fait que remplacer une addiction
par une autre.
Le rapport personnel de Freud à la cocaïne
ne se résume pas à cette mauvaise idée.
Un bon dealer sait qu’il ne doit pas toucher
à sa propre cam’.
Mais voilà, Freud n’est pas un dealer.
Il se met à prendre de la cocaïne :
pour se stimuler ; pour contrôler sa tendance
à la dépression ;
pour se sentir moins stressé dans certaines
situations sociales (comme à la réception
de Charcot) ;
et pour se sentir plus confiant.
Eh oui, la cocaïne décuple la confiance
en soi…
…jusqu’à des niveaux problématiques.
Freud aime tellement la cocaïne qu’il en
envoie par la poste à sa fiancée !
À mes yeux, cette anecdote explique probablement
l’étonnante confiance avec laquelle Freud
défendra ses idées nouvelles.
Parce qu’il y a une disproportion entre,
d’une part, la fragilité des bases « scientifiques
» et intellectuelles des théories psychanalytiques
;
et d’autre part l’assurance avec laquelle
Freud défend ces théories.
D’ailleurs, nous savons aujourd’hui qu’il
a beaucoup généralisé à partir de son
propre cas,
et qu’il a même pas mal menti.
Aurait-il pris ces risques s’il n’avait
pas pris de cocaïne ?
D’ailleurs, la fragilité des idées de
Freud apparaît aux personnes qui s’y intéressent
sérieusement — même aux fans de Freud.
Même à son plus grand partisan, le n°2
de la psychanalyse si on veut.
Carl Gustav Jung travaille avec Freud depuis
les années 1900.
Entre les deux hommes, c’est une véritable
histoire d’amour intellectuelle.
Ils sont tous les deux brillants et ils s’éblouissent
réciproquement,
si bien que lorsqu’ils se rendent visite,
ils peuvent parler 10 heures d’affilée.
Jung admire Freud, dont il a lu les livres,
et Freud voit Jung comme son plus brillant
disciple.
Il le place d’ailleurs à la présidence
de l'Association internationale de psychanalyse.
Mais la relation se détériore dans les années
qui précèdent la Première Guerre mondiale.
Jung, de son côté, se rend compte que Freud
cherche plus l’autorité intellectuelle
que la vérité.
Par exemple, Freud refuse de préciser certains
concepts, notamment la libido ;
il refuse de se laisser analyser, alors que
c’est la règle pour tous les psychanalystes
;
enfin, il donne, aux yeux de Jung, une importance
excessive à la sexualité.
Freud, de son côté, reproche à Jung de
s’aventurer dans des domaines qui sortent
du champ naturel d’application de la psychanalyse,
comme la religion.
Et puis la concurrence entre Jung, facilement
jaloux, et les autres disciples est problématique
pour le développement de la psychanalyse.
En 1914, Jung démissionne de la présidence
de l'Association internationale de psychanalyse
et crée sa propre école de pensée psychologique.
Pour Freud, la déception est profonde.
Il avait placé beaucoup d’espoirs en Jung
; il le voyait comme son potentiel successeur.
Mais il attendait de lui une indéfectible
loyauté.
À mes yeux, cette anecdote révèle la vraie
nature du projet de Freud.
Son but est de promouvoir un mouvement dont
il est le maître.
Freud n’accepte pas facilement, voire pas
du tout, qu’on remette en cause ses idées,
et plus fondamentalement son autorité intellectuelle.
Comparer la psychanalyse freudienne à une
secte — ou à une religion si on veut — c’est
un peu exagéré, mais il y a une part de
vrai.
Comme l’a dénoncé Karl Popper
— qui vivait à Vienne à l’époque où
s’y développait la psychanalyse, au point
que les gens en parlaient dans les cafés
—
selon Karl Popper, Freud a donné à ses idées
l’irréfutabilité d’un dogme religieux.
Puis il a orchestré leur diffusion par ses
disciples un peu à la manière d’une religion.
Je sais que certaines personnes ont une capacité
de travail hors normes.
Par exemple, j’ai bien l’impression qu’Elon
Musk travaille comme un cinglé.
Mais je sais aussi qu’une journée fait
24 heures pour tout le monde,
et que les limites du corps et de l’esprit
sont les mêmes pour tous.
Donc parfois, quand je découvre la routine
de travail d’une personne prétendument
super productive, je n’y crois pas
— je sais qu’il y a un loup.
Prenons Freud, par exemple.
Oui, c’est un travailleur acharné ;
oui, il est très bien organisé, et il a
une puissance de travail hors normes
— et oui, il prend de la coke !
Mais quand même :
sa journée type consiste principalement à
voir entre 6 et 8 patients, le matin et l’après-midi
(et à raison d’une heure par patient, j’imagine)
;
et l’autre plage essentielle de travail,
ce sont les heures de lecture et d’écriture
le soir ;
et à côté de toutes ces heures de travail
au sens strict, il y a divers rendez-vous,
le courrier (comme les mails de nos jours),
les moments passés en famille, les repas,
etc.
Bon, ce qui me paraît suspect, c’est que
Freud prétend effectuer, chaque jour, environ
10 heures de travail nécessitant un haut
niveau de concentration
(les séances avec les patients, la lecture
et l’écriture).
Or, l’esprit humain n’en est pas capable
— même sous cocaïne !
Le bon sens dit que Freud est comme nous,
qu’il ne peut pas rester concentré 10 heures
par jour.
Alors comment fait-il ?
Eh bien il n’est pas concentré pendant
les séances.
Le patient croit que Freud est concentré
— mais il ne l’est pas.
Il accorde à son patient ce qu’il appelle
une « attention flottante ».
D’après lui, ça permet au psychanalyste
de laisser libre cours à ses propres associations,
c’est-à-dire de lever ses biais de confirmation
— autrement dit, c’est une méthode pour
interpréter objectivement la parole du patient.
Mais Freud avouera aussi que l’« attention
flottante » permet d’épargner un effort
d’attention ;
qu’elle s’apparente au demi-sommeil et
conduit parfois au véritable sommeil
(d’ailleurs des patients auxquels il ne
dit rien le soupçonnent de dormir).
Freud se justifiera en disant qu'il économise
son énergie pour suivre beaucoup de patients
chaque jour.
Mouais… on a compris.
Mais bon, c’est vrai que la plupart des
séances sont inintéressantes pour le psychanalyste.
D’ailleurs, si vous interrogez un psychologue,
il vous dira la même chose :
80 % de ses séances sont ennuyantes à mourir
pour lui.
Le psychanalyste écossais Edward Glover conseillera
donc aux analystes
— dans son manuel intitulé La Technique
psychanalytique —
de se forcer à prendre des notes afin de
ne pas s’endormir pendant la séance
(ce qui n’est pas rare, d’après Lacan).
Les psychanalystes mettront cela en pratique…
mais pas forcément dans le sens imaginé
par l’auteur du manuel.
Certains se serviront de la séance pour rédiger
des articles, voire des livres entiers
— tout en prétendant écouter le patient.
Mais Freud avait ouvert la voie :
il a avoué s’être permis, au début de
sa carrière, de profiter de l’état d’hypnose
de certaines patientes pour écrire.
Cette anecdote montre que le fondateur de
la psychanalyse, comme d’autres hommes très
connus, entretient sa légende d’un homme
aux capacités hors normes.
Voilà voilà, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu, que vous avez découvert
des choses intéressantes, et même inspirantes
sur Freud.
Si c’est le cas, donnez un pouce bleu à
la vidéo, et puis laissez un commentaire,
pour améliorer le référencement de la vidéo
— ce n’est pas grand-chose, et ça m’aide
vraiment.
Si ça vous intéresse, sachez qu’il y a
également un cours de culture générale
sur la psychanalyse sur cette chaîne YouTube.
Ça vous permettra de creuser pas mal de choses
dont j’ai parlé dans cette vidéo sur le
mode de l’anecdote.
Je suis Romain, j’étais avec mon fidèle
Haristote, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.
J’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
Croyez-moi :
faites-le,
et vous me remercierez.